[Music]
in student athletes news submitted by
uno dos tres welcome that's one two
three four mine on speakers oh there
yeah no way that's true the NCAA Board
voted to let student athletes endorse
brands and accept sponsors finally what
does the black organization have to do
with this excuse me
Irma the NCAA Athletic Association so
there was a unanimous vote to allow
student athletes to be sponsored by like
to have sponsorships and endorsement
deals more ways to gamble let the
bribery begin no I'm so happy I'm so
happy that is yeah I'm so happy this has
been it's out in the open now cuz it's
been happening oh really
yeah so like oh there's a I'm not gonna
say his name but if you guys know
basketball his initials or KL you went
to my my school for college dude what
don't be painting ass what the [ __ ] is
kale I kept in love I wouldn't know
Kevin love with TC Ellie and I had some
friends that knew him and they have to
hook up be like every single school's
after these high school stars right so
they gotta figure out a way to make them
come to their school because it's
billion trillion dollar business for
their school yes so when they go they
trying to wine and dine and try to do
everything that they can underneath the
table and so I know he got Kevin Love
Gotta Tahoe like a brand new Chevy Tahoe
she got like 60 GS and like a stipend as
a student like just all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] that they have to like kind of
finesse the system to get it to him but
be cut but because they can't be out in
the open and and underneath the table
there's a term for the exact person I
forgot it though like a scout kind of
but they're like the underground Scouts
or like good like they meet up in cars
and the greaser basically I don't know
yeah but when shit's like like I just
called you grease someone up like you
know boo and shit's like illegal like
that
everything can go shady and a lot of
these kids they get taken advantage of
you know don't be like what do you want
three hookers for hookers they do that
kind of [ __ ] but then why are you
excited that it's out in the open so
that now it doesn't have to be done in
the shady way and then these kids want
money yeah they won't get taken
advantage of cuz I like to imagine or a
17 year old kid some guy just comes up
to you and go buy a Toyota Camry you're
like oh [ __ ] but then now we never say
oh [ __ ]
especially not without a Toyota Camry
you're not from Alabama they play
basketball in the dirt on a dirt road
you know it some of these kids at 17 I
would have been oh [ __ ] if a Toyota
Camry came my way it could even be used
five years old where the camera my first
car was a Toyota Camry that's what you
don't know you don't know what these
people are from all right so when you
have if you have things that are now
legal now you have agents and managers
are able to go down to the student level
and they can see what all the pitches
are enacted help make the best decision
so these stupid the right Toyota Camry
exactly someone gave me a 1980 Honda
Accord I would have been like hell yeah
anything that [ __ ] drives they don't
even give you a car and it's just the
[ __ ] clothes that says Camry you're
down dude it could be no it could be a
straw with four donuts and it's all in a
car you should have Ford Escort t-shirts
I think they do because they're like the
college sports league
it's almost as profitable as the
professional league but they're but
they're getting taken advantage of
they're pretty much like all like
non-paid they are so much money off it
and then like let's say you get an
injury you're done oh yeah you're done
yeah and then you don't have an
insurance plan like you you put all your
eggs in one basket and then they're like
okay I'm just gonna focus on basketball
I'm not even gonna focus on my major and
then like let's say you tear some [ __ ]
which we all know people that get hurt
in college is supposed to be the next
star and their whole futures [ __ ]
that's why a lot of people think that
the NCAA is one of the most corrupt
organizations like there is because of
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] and they and
they slap rule down on certain people
and certain people get passes like
depending on who got grease where yeah
that kale he kind of also back in a day
Gatorade had it be like
is that there's actually a mini
documentary on YouTube by SP nation if
you guys know Laremy Tunsil know he's a
football player so he went through the
whole process got recruited but in his
deal he had to go to us different school
he chose another school so on draft
night
the people who greased him up they
leaked the video of him like smoking
weed with a black male so he was
projected to be yeah he was projected be
a top 3 pick and if you go down in the
draft you lose money like millions it's
like you didn't want to join you went
from a top oh yeah I think he ended up
being drafted like 18 if you go to
school at these fools hmm it's crazy
it's literally a celebrity walking on
campus like when Kevin Love or Russell
Westbrook was just walking down the quad
and they're just and they're just a
nerve act because you're still going to
class swarms of girls come out of
nowhere dudes come and they want to take
pictures with them because they already
know they're gonna be an NBA star so
it's [ __ ] insane if you have like a
young 17 or 18 year old kid that has
that kind of startup it's easy to get
blackmail cuz the opposite opposite
school or opposite breath cuz send a hot
chick in there get the guys hot dude
maybe ha dude do it after party do some
coke do some weed it's so easy to take
advantage of these young ass kids if you
just fill them nowadays everybody has a
camera so it's [ __ ] night so this
decision is like almost famous being
Uncle Sam until I saw these fools walk
around on my water [ __ ] if it's legal
then they can have representation they
could have agents fighting for them they
can yeah and it'll be all out in the
open because they were saying that last
year NCAA reported total revenues of
more than 1 billion dollars an 80% of
which came from television marketing
rights whew oh they got a billion
dollars but the industry I heard is like
12 or 13 billion or some [ __ ] by the
whole thing I was saying that like hot
dogs on French concession stands no no
like I think that 1 billion just for the
NCAA's is a lot for one organization but
I I was thinking that the whole industry
is a billion when she said the billion
words
like [ __ ] that's small yeah but then
it's it's actually just you not even not
even that we're just talking about March
to like just for sports merch there's
like million dollar companies out there
just for college sports merch I mean
dude you should see the people I mean
dude the stadiums get [ __ ] packed
like it's crazy all the same colors are
all wearing the merch seventy thousand
seats sometimes like it's [ __ ] nuts
man college balls like for real and I
alumni go every single year especially
those big rivalry games like they will
pay big bucks to sometimes I feel bad
for like the loser sports yeah badminton
team what are they feeling yeah because
you see you gonna watch like a football
basketball game and then like let's say
you play [ __ ] WNBA what about the La
Crosse egg lacrosse team and then
there's only like 50 people in the
audience yeah but you play on the same
field and you're like they don't get the
same funding well I didn't get the same
viewers either that's true I mean Jesus
go watch a bowling [ __ ] league thing
it's I like bowling you know it's
actually fun though I was watching
Little League the little big ESPN ten
things it's [ __ ] hilarious yeah I was
with George Kimmel up and we're seeing
the Palm Springs and we watched an
entire little league baseball game
because it's [ __ ] hilarious how
little you watch because some of those
kids are crazy already
they're like up to bat 11 year old Brian
Johnson and he's 511 you're like what
the [ __ ] was these were like little kids
Oh like toddlers four-year-old oh they
were probably like nine huh yeah but
like they're hitting balls and going
like and like before they even run the
base or like cheering for themselves
like you're [ __ ] about the base -
that's true Tim I hope those kids are
getting free tacos [ __ ] I know that walk
away like it probably starts there
nowadays you start um televising high
school basketball certain high school
right LeBron started that trend but now
it's even middle school every prospect
has a highlight tape on YouTube you just
like visors I just showed Casey and
Barlow like Shaq's kids - right yeah
yeah like LeBron LeBron's kids here
they're LeBron and Dwayne Wade's kid or
son go to the same
in LA now I would hate to be there kids
because imagine all that pressure
basketball and then you go home and you
get lost in your own 26 bedroom mansion
can you find the bathroom in here oh
wait there's 70 of them we're kids they
have to go in the backyard and practice
on the court on their own full court
sucks or their gym their indoor gym that
they have like yeah man
take a Lamborghini Huracan just shopping
must really be hard yeah well cuz if
you're parking that thing you ding it
like that's $30,000 really low to the
floor
yeah so that mean you don't know any
better who are those two tennis sisters
not this not the twins
Serena sisters weren't twins no but
there's another set because he I was
like those are still there yeah when I'm
sisters you talking about the other the
other anyways yeah that's that yeah but
they were saying that they don't want
their kids to play tennis at all because
of brain injuries well it sounds like
you're making it sound like that I think
it's the pressure and the lifestyle oh I
see of being an athlete to get to make a
lot and do all that I think you know
it's it's not really the life they want
for their be great feel like I don't
want my kids to play because it's pretty
boring
how the [ __ ] people watch golf brother
my dad used to love playing it and
watching that's the best sport though
the least amount of work you don't break
this way you get to wear slacks and then
you make a [ __ ] ton of money in the
longevity I would never buy a commercial
for golf you know why cuz that's how
much money no I always think about I
always think about when I saw my grandpa
watching golf
he's always dead [ __ ] sleep in the
chair
the afternoon golf is on and they're
probably running all kinds ads he never
felt what the cigar just burning all by
itself got some whiskey news handy they
don't [ __ ] nobody watches that she I
think they'll just fall asleep with it
on that's true but they have a channel
that it they have a golf channel though
like a challenge
it's a big [ __ ] they have a whole
channel for weather like oh you got
motive what does that mean it means that
Grunwald you know the driving range is
fun as [ __ ] though every time the golf
cart comes to like try to collect all
the everyone tries to hit that [ __ ]
spot and dude that's not as fuzzy
because like
some kid in married he's like I know my
life already sucks like [ __ ] you you got
one right here it's true though we do
everyone does try to hit that [ __ ]
yeah yeah I do I never played like
actual golf golf though I would like to
try play mini golf I've never played a
hurt I've heard it's hard mini golf is
fun yeah and just the driving range is
fun too so we should just [ __ ] I did
edibles and did mini golf once sounds
like a party I would love to see Steve
on it was playing mini I know me too
it was like all this underwater I was
like is this an underwater theme and
they're like No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]